ager dinkle edge Yallah carpet ride  check out leoz I wonder what he's  dreaming about he is probably dreaming  about what we is gonna do to the team in  the West I wonder to various myths t  king for sure I'm a bad manager at an  awful sport smoochie-wallace you could  call me ty royal wrapping up rushes like  aluminum foil between you best be wary  of carpet Ron don't marry him  I love the ball so much I want to marry  [Music]  we are the best  I'm into brahim boys - and my rhymes are  clean that my name was dr. Seuss shelter  him that's my name  power candles sounds the same with Jack  and Harry the sweater he borrows from  the mall like that Watson played sax Axl  Marcus played guitar  [Music]  okay don't you know  [Music]  indeed to be a better it must have been  all a dream or was it oh it song  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  got some Dan Smith and the West is  getting rowdy like lost  [Applause]  you